do you like what Korea's doing with
movies well yeah I mean sympathy for Mr
de sympathy for Mr Vengeance was what
made me want to make hostile I saw that
by myself at a screening at the sites
Film Festival 2 o'clock in the afternoon
when I was there with cin fever and my
jaw was on the ground I was like this is
the best film I've seen in years and one
of the best movies in my lifetime and
nobody's in the [__] theater and I
actually sent a tape of it around to
like Quenton before he went to can to be
a judge I'm like I think Park chanook is
the best director in the world right now
and then Harry NOS got a 35 print of old
boy before had titles on it before mirx
bought it and we screened it at his all
night movie so i' had seen an early
screening of BU booy and then I wed up
writing director Park's immigration
letter like there was there was a
screening like the Korean Society USC
the Korean like they found out that I
was like a fan of his and they're like
we want to would you host a screening of
sympathy for Mr Vengeance with director
Park he's coming to town so I like drove
down to USC with these students with
like me and him there's photos of us
from like 2004 hosting hosting so I was
like very onto Korean Cinema and I
talked about it in all here's
interesting I talked about Korean Cinema
for all my press for hosel and then
people started coming up to me going
have you seen the squid game you seen
squid game and everyone's like there's a
lot of similar stuff in Squid game so I
watched it and I of course loved it but
there's the business card there's the
rich people payt there's a lot of themes
and I and I met the Creator met director
dong and I and I talked to him and he
was just like you don't understand he's
like when I was writing squid game all I
was watching was hostile and host
and I'm with like you know H like the
cast he's like everyone Eli's like this
is what inspired Squig I'm like no no no
you understand sympathy for Mr Vengeance
is what inspired hostile so the fact
that it went full circle with Korean
Cinema that I was so inspired to make
hostile and then he was so inspired by
hostile to make squid game it's like
we're all dealing with very we're all
like in you know very interesting
similar themes of power and people that
are so wealthy they're bored and and
violence is entertaining
people that are so numb that they have
to do something violent to stimulate so
it was just it was amazing it was an
amazing moment to meet them and have
that like connection of Cinema come in
Full Circle that's that's the beauty of
Art in any language you know and the in
the genre Cinema is that it does
translate you know there's certain
things that are Universal do you pinch
yourself well not no but I mean you look
at your life and go wow I do I really do
I look like that I was I watched the
print of Thanksgiving this morning I
checked it and and I sat there and like
my friend Jeff and I have had this idea
since we were 13 or 12 growing up in
Boston with every slasher holiday with
silent night deadly night Halloween 2 3
4 my you know April Fool's Day My Bloody
Valentine everything had a holiday
Mother's Day we were like when are they
doing Thanksgiving they like there's
Think Tank you pull a lever and it comes
out and I was like we're like we need
Thanksgiving that's the one that's like
non-religious it applies to everybody
and you could have like a killer like
someone you know is in love with a
turkey and then they chop turkey head
off had all kinds of different ideas of
what this movie should be and then it
was uh you know Grindhouse Quenton was
like hey do you want to do a fake
trailer for Grindhouse so we did I was
like I already got the movie it's
already written Thanksgiving so we just
basically came up with crazy kills which
was a a human human at a parade in a
turkey costume gets decapitated and then
stumbles around like a chicken with her
head cut off their head cut off so and
then it's someone being roasted as a
human turkey like all these things but
that was a joke well but imagine being
12 and 13 years old and sitting there
going okay if think of this if they made
a Thanksgiving you could take someone
roast them like a turkey and then put
the little Chef's hats on their
toes and yeah and then there we were as
like adults going like no the chef's
hats have to have a little more C I want
this and we're like doing it with this
with Adrien Maro who won the Oscar for
the whale for makeup he does this
beautiful body that's like everyone else
is so repulsed by him like this is a
work of art there should be in a museum
you know and it's got like he he did
like a
really uh well I don't want to I don't
want to give it away but there's there's
great stuff so there is a thing where I
was watching it this morning you know
and I called Jeff after I was emotional
I was like I was like I can't believe
there's Billboards I'm like we did it
like our childhood dream if we never
accomplish anything else in our lives we
[__] did it we got the Thanksgiving
horror movie so you can have that
calendar you can just check that month
off so so you don't have to wait till
December you can go October November you
get a horror film and December there'll
be there'll be Santa slasher movies we
didn't want to go a month November
sucked cuz there were there weren't
going to be any new horror movies
Halloween was over you had to wait till
Christmas but now we filled that Gap you
want [__] November I was like I want
horror movies in November and I want to
thank is there Easter one there's I I
want to do an Easter one I could
basically just make holiday horror for
the rest of my life yeah but yeah not
mainstream yet but that's my goal yeah
wow dude so yeah I do pinch myself a lot
all the time I'm like I can't believe
and and you know what it's great I think
the pandemic really rattled all of us in
so many ways we're just like okay if we
never let out of our houses if we're let
out of our houses again and this thing
if this thing gets worse what's going to
happen it made everyone really just
clean [__] out get rid of your B
projects only focus on your a project
and I thought you know maybe I don't
know what's going to happen this is it
the next movie I have to make has to be
Thanksgiving because that might be the
last film I ever get to do cuz who the
[__] knows what's going to happen so
that's and I think that's the way you
got of got to approach every movie
really like if I never do anything else
this is the one I'll tell you Eli um
having you here this is like mesmerizing
because I don't get you the only I've
only had a couple directors I've had Jud
and Jordan and Jordan and but because I
love film and um I really like love you
as a human being I love you too and um
is there anything else you want to plug
I mean